digo él sí sí porque parece que va a
planear algo secreto para ti
Eso es amor de verdad
si tuvieras que compararte con otros en
función de un rasgo específico Que
dirías sobre cómo los Ven y cómo te ven
reunimos a cinco parejas e hicimos que
los novios se clasificaran a sí mismos
en función de lo atractivos que creen
que son luego invitamos a sus novias a
que los reordenen Esta es la
clasificación me llamo Calvin Tengo 23
años y cultivo Cannabis yo soy Ryan
tengo 25 años y trabajo en una empresa
de tecnología soy Dominic tengo 21 años
soy estudiante y trabajo en consultoría
tecnológica Hola Mi nombre es Marta Vega
hoy he cumplido 28 años soy youtuber
agente inmobiliario y un actor
Mi nombre es Mika tengo 21 años obtendré
mi licencia para conducir camiones
comerciales A quién creen que
encontrarán más atractivo
en el grupo yo diría aquí
era ya saben solo basado en una primera
impresión que sería clasificado como el
más alto porque tiene la apariencia
tenía la altura tenía el color de ojos
lo sabes iba a decir Mika solo el estilo
el cabello parece muy relajado puedo
decir yo mismo yo diría yo mismo
sí iba a decir que te pareces a Andrew
Garfio eso me lo dicen mucho
me acabo de dar cuenta que te pareces a
Edward Cullen Ah músculo
todos los días Por cierto me gusta la
barba Gracias mucho No me puedo dejar
crecer la barba así
Tenía que estar bien para las cámaras
iba a hacerme un corte fresco
Normalmente me hago un desvanecimiento
aquí cero Estoy celoso me encanta Yo
también creen que sus novias los
encontraron negativos cuando los
conocieron Yo diría que sí porque el
primer día que nos conocimos ya nos
besamos cuando la conocí ella trabajaba
con un restaurante y me invitó a salir
Entonces definitivamente pensó que yo
era atractivo en realidad no estoy
seguro Porque casi me dejó
el visto y casi no me respondió después
de que empecé a hablar con ella pero
creo que me encuentra atractivo porque
la ayudo a lidiar con las emociones sé
que eso es algo importante y soy como su
compañero para eso Tuvimos una gran
primera cita Así que creo que sí me
presenté con un aspecto muy atrevido
tenía un pendiente con forma de espada y
vestía todo de negro hoy en día siento
que me visto más como un papá Así que
los tiempos han cambiado
uno es el más alto pienso lo mismo
mereces estar ahora bien estaba pensando
en mantener el número 2 tiene Barba es
increíble No sé estoy muy firme en el
número dos contigo de hecho iba a decir
número dos para ti puedes debe estar ahí
también
creo que deberías estar aquí te pareces
a alexby
número 13 sí tienes razón Sí estoy de
acuerdo con eso creo que podría estar en
el lugar equivocado creo que tengo que
ir en esa dirección
es una decisión es un empate porque te
pareces a Andrew garfiel más o menos él
se parece
más lo veo
Yo diría que es 1 2 3 podría estar de
acuerdo contigo en eso mi clasificación
sería Honestamente creo que tú mica dos
tres cuatro cinco sí uno
como quiere hacer dos
probablemente te ponga en tres cuatro o
cinco entonces qué dirías yo diría uno
dos tres yo seré cuatro y cinco Me
parece bien estar entre 3 y 5
pero tengo tres más cuatro
Y si hacemos una clasificación basada en
la personalidad diré que uno por la
personalidad bien Eres muy graciosa
delante de nosotros llévennos hacia
abajo todavía ustedes deberíamos
averiguar el orden pero si Ustedes deben
estar arriba Sí tú crees que deberías
ser el número para mí también es un
dilema porque me gusta tu personalidad
eres genial sí creo que debería estar
arriba también porque eres realmente
genial está claro te pondría delante de
mí sinceramente estoy hablando en serio
Voy a subir aquí
crees que deberías también probablemente
Debería ser uno basándose en su aspecto
y personalidad realmente creo que mica
Debería ser una gracias gracias
creo que debería tener dos porque estaba
muy seguro de sí mismo sí
me resulta difícil calificarte debajo de
mí estaría encantado
Sinceramente mi personalidad es nula así
que sí sí
Esta es su clasificación final están
contentos Yo diría que sí sí sí sí
[Música]
para mí es más el físico obviamente que
la atracción personalmente no Me
sentiría atraída por él de buenas a
primeras pero habla muy bien la forma en
que te habló a ti y la forma en la que
se presentó fue realmente dulce lo
clasificaría en la parte superior sin
duda tal vez uno o dos
número uno por supuesto
número 2 por su cabello y somos el mismo
color así que automático
sinceramente lo pongo como número uno
para la mayoría sí seguro ya sabes su
cumpleaños
obviamente mi hombre estaría en el
número uno
número dos yo digo él sí sí la forma en
que sale parece tan amigable también
parece el tipo de hombre que sería un
buen novio para ella
parece Parece que va a planear algo
secreto para ti definitivamente
eso es amor de verdad voy a ir con mi
novio primero
quedarse más crédito a sí mismo voy a
pasar al segundo lugar sí tiene una
buena personalidad muy buena pero
también Calvin se forma en la que dijo
aprendo mi confianza de ti realmente me
pareció dulce Sí el número uno
el número 2 la camisa de cuadros
simplemente me gusta el estilo es algo
que creo que llevaría Honestamente
también es divertido una personalidad
tan brillante te sientes naturalmente
atraída por su esencia que
bien
sin rencores creo que todo el mundo es
hermoso y magnífico
número 1 específicamente por su
personalidad las joyas El golpe de
cabeza cuando estaba escuchando música
número 2 por la forma en la que se
presentaba y hablaba sobre su pareja era
tan lindo número 3 gracioso desenfadado
alegre número 4 algo callado pero
divertido y el número 5 sin rencores
ninguno es un 5 mis ojos pero no era de
mi gusto personal
haré lo mejor número 1 que es un
semental
número 2 realmente me encanta el cabello
el estilo y Súper divertido número 3 el
estilo es genial 4 energético tiene una
personalidad que parece realmente genial
como Misteriosa quiere saber más y luego
el 5 sigue siendo muy atractivo Pero no
es mi tipo a cada uno lo suyo
[Música]
es el número uno porque creo que es muy
genial
número 2 Creo que debería darse más
crédito número 3 no sé mucho sobre su
personalidad pero lo que veo es que es
realmente genial
número 4 parece un tipo amable y número
5 es atractivo pero el atractivo es
subjetivo
el primero
No espacial
simplemente lo encuentro muy divertido
segundo gran personalidad gran persona
tercero tiene un aspecto ordinario
cuarto es un tipo dulce
cinco tiene mucha confianza en sí mismo
pero personalmente no lo encuentro
atractivo
bien el número lo pongo porque lo
encuentro realmente atractivo el número
2 lo pongo como un empate porque
uno me gusta la energía pero no me
atraería si pasara mucho tiempo pero el
otro me sentía atraída pero no realmente
no creo que pudiera estar con él
número 4 Simplemente no es para mí
número 5 Simplemente no me interesan los
temas que aprendí sobre esa persona así
que no Quiero escucharla Gracias por
venir a mi charla
[Aplausos]
Calvin vamos a moverte cambia de lugar
con Ryan
personalmente es lo que es solo intento
impresionar a una persona así que no me
molesto demasiado Ryan cambiemos del
lugar con Don
sí
vamos a cambiar de lugar con Marc
Y por último mica cambia de lugar con
Marc
mica lo siento
Y esa es la puntuación media de las
chicas tú
pensé realmente que iba a ser tres o
cuatro Honestamente solo solo porque
sabía que me faltaba un poco de altura
pero ganó mi personalidad nunca pensé
que iba a ser el número uno nunca Y
pensé que Dominic iba a ser el número
uno no sé creo que simplemente
apreciaron mi cabello y el hecho de que
me parezca a Edward Cullen eso me ayudó
mucho o todavía estoy sorprendido de
estar aquí muy muy sorprendido Qué
opinan de su clasificación